it's so new they're still moving into
this manufacturing and development
facility in coventry
the only center of its kind in the uk
they make batteries for everything from
trains to planes
and electric cars in the city that gave
birth to the motor industry
there's a sense of pride at being part
of the journey to net zero
this facility forms part of the jigsaw
of activities required
to develop technology and and drive that
through
the market and which which will reduce
climate change in the uk and the rest of
the world in fact in time this hall will
be
full of people manufacturing and packing
batteries the prime minister wants
facilities like this to help make
britain
a world leader on tackling climate
change
overall this is a package which is part
of
turbocharging the green industrial
revolution that the prime minister set
out
levelling up across our country the
government says it wants places like the
west midlands with its manufacturing
heritage
to be at the forefront of the green
revolution but compared to other
countries there are questions about how
much
money boris johnson is spending on his
10-point
climate plan the government's own
advisory body the committee on climate
change
says between 20 and 40 billion pounds a
year
needs to be spent to get to net zero by
2050
the think tank the ippr puts the figure
at 33 billion
but the new climate plan commits to 12
billion and only a third of that is new
money
i don't think what's been announced uh
is enough to get us to net zero
we set out what we think he's needed to
get there which is 33
billion pounds a year just a few weeks
ago the government had only invested
a tenth of that so far and what's been
announced today another 4 billion
will help but it will not bridge the gap
critics say the spending scatters money
on new technology such as nuclear energy
and
carbon capture without enough focus on
major issues like decarbonizing our
homes
public transport and nature based
solutions
there's a lot of green talk but not
enough green
action if you like the rhetoric and the
reality
are quite far divorced and what we need
is is with is more urgency
more ambition and a credible and
comprehensive plan
britain is changing as we try to reduce
the amount of emissions we produce
the 10-point plan gives a new sense of
momentum
but we're entering uncharted territory
about how best to tackle the climate
emergency
lisa holland sky news